welcome back Billy thanks thanks for
having me back man like last time we
talked to you we talked a little about
this movie but it was almost
conceptually I think last time I just
like is this just a movie about Alex
Rodriguez doing steroids cuz we didn't
know anything about it but like I was
telling Travis that I watched it without
knowing really I mean I knew baseball
players did steroids but I didn't know
the story and it is unbelievable like is
this has the documentary of an option to
be a movie movie yet because it's it's
Fargo level insanity it should be like a
cartoon yes yeah yeah animated movie yes
it's so weird it's bizarre that that's
the thing it's like we've been making
documentaries for almost 20 years and
mainly about Florida primarily about
flux because why not because Florida
yeah it's really source
rich rich with content Richard material
yeah
and so but this is the most meticulously
researched project we've ever done
because we're dealing with some pretty
litigious sure are a few people here in
in Alex Rodriguez in Major League
Baseball and so we wanted to make sure
we were very careful about everything
you said everything was vetted by
absolutely superseded it's also
absolutely ridiculous insane it doesn't
make any sense then it's totally stupid
nobody's motivations make sense nobody
and but it's all true then you wouldn't
believe it if it weren't so when you do
something like this like at what put
where the things in there that a lawyer
said no we can't have it even though we
think it's true we can't prove it with
if certain things they made you take out
not really not anything that I wanted to
put in per se there were certain places
where some of the characters were
commentating for example they offered a
the steroid doctor I'm dad I'm sorry air
quotes doctor who I would call him a
fake doctor but he makes it plain that
just because he doesn't have a medical
license that's valid in the United
States is not making a fake doctor we
actually it's one of the longest takes
in any documentary that I've ever made
because our stuff like cocaine Cowboys
is pretty renowned for its fast cutting
so this is the longest shot I've ever
left in a documentary it's him
Toni Bosch describing the distinction
without a difference between a fake
doctor and an unlicensed physician okay
when it takes offense to it sure when I
saw him so there's there's photos a man
of science
photos like in real life like before
this documentary is a documentary there
were already photos out there of his
medical jacket that said dr. Tony
whatever his name Tony Basha
Tony Bosch dr. Tony bah she's like dr.
NIC from The Simpsons doctor I'm sitting
there going
he's clearly like this this happened for
real he's not gonna be able to say I
didn't say it was a doctor so when I i
sat there when I realized that that's
what this shot was him explaining why
he's not a fake doctor he's actually
offended the people said he was because
he does not have a medical license but
and he called himself doctor yes but he
had a full explanation for it and I said
you know what Tony I'm with you now I'm
with you dr. T does a rod support this
documentary not expecting the invitation
to the wedding I'll tell you that right
now actually it's funny
so our distributor Greenwich
Entertainment they released free solo
that won the Oscar for Best Documentary
this year they they put out the trailer
a couple weeks ago and started to gain a
little traction people were talking
about it people dug it and the very next
day Instagram a rod on one knee
proposing to JLo I wanted to text a rods
publicist who I know and go well played
bro did you talk tell us because I saw
part of the documentary the kids in it
was so smart and it was such an
interesting way to tell a story did you
tell us you were gonna do that I'm like
I think yeah we talked about we did okay
a little bit the reenactment is all the
reenactments are done with kids yeah and
when I fertile you when I first what
turned on the movie I was like I don't
know if I need this this is kind of dumb
well you realize that these are probably
kids they don't partly Delta Pi older
they're actually over 18 when this was
mustache is fake nobody that age and
growing I don't think nobody puberty
brings facial hair and there I was like
I was think I was watching and I'm going
like why do you need this and then when
the story starts to get a silly and
ridiculous as it gets I went this is
perfect this
perfect way to tell this story because
it doesn't make sense that adults would
behave in this way it doesn't thank you
but and when we make sports
documentaries we did the you four
examples for talking also thank you
lovely thanks so much that's awesome
their team was crazy yeah crazy yeah you
did - you did - you are - yeah because
if it ain't broke don't fix it right as
well am I not um I wonder what I say
some I might not be a you know a one-hit
wonder but I might be a one-trick pony
that's totally possible but um put you
in Florida and let you just go - yeah
all right listen sport stocks are pretty
straightforward I mean I don't want to
belittle anyone's angst Doc's are hard
to make but sports Doc's are kind of
patient by numbers I love your movies
that's the only thing that's ever taken
me out of your movie is in cocaine
Cowboys one of the first interviews were
there explaining the the plane who's the
blond guy with Mickey Barry seal Barry
seal Pablo Escobar yeah but when Mickey
is giving when Mickey's giving the
interview I was like I love the movie I
love cooking cowboys but he's talking
and then he moves in it you see has a
ponytail and I was like I'll [ __ ] all
this what a [ __ ] joke about it it's
like in my stand-up back because I was
like have you ever had a conversation
with a guy then realized he had a
ponytail it throws you off with your
interview it was like [ __ ] back you
know yeah so comes out he looks like he
look like a bad guy from a die hard
movie he turned his head so [ __ ] so
screwball if followed for people who
don't know and we're just kind of you
know talking in pieces group screwball
like that the story is that there was
this guy who wasn't an actual doctor but
he'd gone to medical school outside
physician who's unlicensed position I
please sticking up for him was like
Tony's a good guy so one of the
interview subjects refers to the school
he went to as the Belize School of the
medical and Performing Arts
but he starts this business in Florida
that's supposed to be like a it's it's
to use to keep your youth when you get
older anti-aging anti-aging clinic
and but realistically three hand your
gun and adultery
realistically he's dealing steroids and
he's connected with all these like shady
Florida drug dealers and and and
criminals and questionable characters
questionable characters and just a an
insane array of people around him each
one of them deserves their own
documentary but it talks about how he
ends up in connection with these
baseball players and then how the a
major league baseball ends up being just
as crazy as the rest of them and how
stupid the whole thing got but what
stopped me in my tracks was Porter
Fisher maybe and I don't know if you got
that fortune but Porter Fisher may be
the greatest character in cinematic
history Porter Fisher is this guy he's
the one who really blew the lid off the
whole thing whistle blower
he's the whistle blow we do it on
purpose with it by mistake he did it on
purpose but it was because the good
doctor Tony owed him four grand and
wouldn't pay him the four grand I like a
guy that'll turn over four four girls
isn't it crazy how people [ __ ]
themselves for such a miniscule amount
of money so he ended up anybody ended up
not making any money off of any of it
everybody around him he had stole all
this evidence everybody around him found
out about it and by the way everybody
around him is criminals is that by the
way when the opening scene of the thing
the cars yes that's it they are stealing
the stolen evidence yes so that they can
sell it not to the highest bidder but to
every bidder and all the one who will
pay anything for it because he's
surrounded by these just by virtue of
being in Miami and hanging out at
24-hour tanning salon that's what he
does do and he goes he goes like this
well you know I hung out at the tanning
salon all the time because you know I
enjoy it I enjoy tanning that's what I
do I'm a professional tanner the [ __ ]
son that was brought up we discuss it
it's the it is it we have more sunshine
like per year than any state in the
Union and yet this proliferation of fake
tanning salons let me just scribble what
immediately would stop me from hanging
out with someone is it they're like I'm
into tanning well we are not gonna be
friends you some anchorage knock
yourself from florida
you're a real [ __ ] cooked idiot
really turns his head in this now is a
rod you wonder when this is happening
this a rod knows that all this craziness
is happening and is he [ __ ] panicking
like there's no is it welcome all with
information oh yeah well Iran and Major
League Baseball were just it was like
Keystone Cops
on the ground in Miami and they were
they were throwing both sides millions
of dollars this became a whole cottage
industry in Miami for pies and private
investigators and attorneys and then
these felons who could steal documents
and they were selling the stolen radical
records to MLB for a hundred and twenty
five grand cash Jesus to a convicted
felon in a diner in Miami or in South
Florida and then the same felons are
video recording the transaction so they
can sell the video to a rod of them
selling like mo B's got a slush fund and
a run around with like duffel bags of
cash and then they sell a rod a blank
harddrive just it's sold I wonder if
Barry Bonds is watching this as laughing
Jose Canseco certainly is yeah not too
happy with a-rod some reason that's the
other that's the other thing that a rob
was banging like he said a rob was
trying to [ __ ] his like Jose's ex-wife I
don't but sure or not but he went right
out there and said it right about the
the to [ __ ] up the engagement Jose
doesn't keep things under his hat I like
it but so so so Porter Porter Fisher
he's sitting there like he's in a
tanning salon he meets dr. Tony there it
just hangs out of the literally hangs
out in Phoenix dr. nuclear the base or
was he going for dr. Tony likes to tan
he loves doing cocaine and he has no
problem talking about how loves cocaine
the amount of his fake tips that have
been in that man's face tons of them but
he loves cocaine and tanning and that's
where he meets Porter but he knows that
Porter is kind of a doofus and
unfortunately Porter is portrayed as a
bit of a doofus in the
but I think he does that himself he's
very earnest he's very earnest that's
who he is
but so dr. Tony ends up opening one of
these age centers right by the tanning
salon there so Porter is now friends
with dr. Tony Annie
they say he just starts hanging out in
the lobby yes all day every day and you
realize that this is what Porter does he
just hangs out in a spot his Porter
mentally [ __ ] I don't think so
because there's a guy in the East
Village just hangs out in this pharmacy
and I think they're kind of like hangs
out water gets he gets hit by car I mean
the insurance settlement it gets there
an insurance settlement for it then dr.
Tony finds out about it all of a sudden
dr. Tony is friends with him dr. Tony
says if you give me the four thousand
dollars you could do my marketing and
then I'll pay you back forty eight
hundred over the course of four weeks
and dr. t puts that money directly up
his nose and then dr. teeth he's making
his explanations for he's like look I
was running out of money I got a very
expensive lifestyle you know I got two
apartments two rents child support
yeah child support and then I all my
cocaine he's like five six grand a month
like okay you were hurt what is this
cocaine bill as if one receives leave
like Con Ed once in a while he'll get a
clean energy option you want to go
paperless with you you know what with my
new chase app chase takes care of my
granddaughter monthly it's like movie
pass but for cocaine so oh man all these
leathered skin [ __ ] yeah Porter
accepts the deal he goes that's actually
sounds like a great deal I'll give you
the $4,000 and he hands it to him of
course because of cocaine and other
reasons dr. Tony decides against paying
Porter back you guys I'm not gonna be
you've gotten the money from if he said
look this guy's about to blab give me
the money wouldn't anyone have handed
him five grand the problem is it's too
late this whole thing explodes just like
four weeks this guy Porter is on a short
fuse jacked up on yeah Jesus Walker
y'all talking anybody a lot of impulse
on this guy that's where this all comes
to first of all you described it so so
beautifully it's to the point where I'm
sitting I'm like that's [ __ ] doesn't
make any sense right that's bizarre such
a great story and and it's like a Coen
Brothers movie yes like this these like
misguided like everybody makes the wrong
decision and we're not if it makes sense
why would you do this
and then Porter's got all this evidence
that's very very valuable MLB's trying
to buy it you know that there's a
obviously a rods people are trying to
buy it everybody's trying to buy it he
don't know who to sell it to so he picks
nobody he's not selling it to anybody
he's like no there's call him they're
like we'll give you $125,000 for it he
goes no I'm not doing that I bonded with
the information yeah because he's
worried about getting killed so he's not
selling it he's gonna keep it because
why cuz because if you're gonna kill him
you definitely gonna kill him if he's
still got the other I don't know what
yeah so he doesn't so he doesn't do
anything except he tells his criminal
friends that he's got all this very
valuable evidence he wants to buy so
that his criminal friends go oh come to
the tanning salon and while he's in the
talent tanning salon they take all of
the evidence out of his car literally
he's getting a spray tan and they're
robbing the records from his car and
then they sell it all
that's how everybody found out about the
steroids because they just go all this
stolen evidence is for sale cuz he had
it in his car and Major League Baseball
and all the other organizations they
don't care they're like stolen evidence
yeah we'll purchase that so perspective
the career of the highest-paid baseball
player in history yes effectively ended
over a $4,000 debt between a cocaine
addicted fake doctor and his fake
tanning addicted steroid page that's so
crazy
that's amazing yeah this is awesome that
he's just getting that [ __ ] spray and
he's like no but I tell you I felt good
you did he was just he was like oh I'm
gonna look so golden yeah hey by the way
the only people he told about it were
his criminal friends and they're like
well what about the people you told
about he goes no that doesn't make any
sense they couldn't have done it you
tell your friends that have a criminal
history goes what's up
what
what did you tell your friends he goes
yeah I wouldn't what's up with that my
friends I wouldn't do that yeah they're
the good guys I was getting a tan they
watch my car they drive it around
because there's no parking but Jim you
ask you hey rod was nervous the reason
he met the doctor who is Manny Ramirez
was the first guy write me an Ramirez
was the first guy that got busted yes
yeah so many Ramirez gets busted but
before he got busted he was a hell of a
player yeah a rata cording to this
documentary I believe you Billy he goes
to the doctor and says whatever you're
giving Manny Ramirez just give that to
me I want what Manny was having it seems
careless seems so doesn't it yeah but
listen when you're at that point in your
career Alex was definitely towards the
end of his career and your body is your
fortune and you're just trying to do
everything you can to reverse the how
bad is that stuff for you physically is
it really that bad physically or that
just cheating they were taking primarily
what Bosch was doing was the
testosterone and human growth hormone so
it's not like the same [ __ ] that like
the baseball beasts you know the Hulk's
of the 90s we're using like they're
using that Arnold Schwarzenegger yeah
you know but this is if you went to a
legitimate doctor they could some they
could prescribe you this the illegal in
baseball it's a right exactly it's so
when they say illegal or banned
substance they mean contractually
between the players and their and
baseball sure but I mean it's not a lot
of guys I know do testosterone they're
x-fighters and they swear by it and they
go no it's not bad for you that's gotten
a bad rap it's not gonna hurt you
absolutely listen to something we
naturally produce and as you get older
you produce less of it and if you're
trying to reverse that that aging those
aging effects it's something that you do
and a lot of people do do it that's why
thinks the anti-aging clinics the
problem is it's like like everything
else in Florida it's like this gray
market economy you know it's not
and a most successful [ __ ] football
team in history and you still gotta get
jerked off for a hundred yeah was this
fistic about Florida and fraud it was
some kind of there's some kind of
statistic in the movie the Florida fraud
makes up a huge percentage of Florida
Connor we are the Medicare fraud capital
of the country yes we in in miami-dade
county alone in Medicare Medicaid
payments this is mostly elderly people
you know I will eat those yeah well he
does they receive the most amount of
money in aids and HIV medication
payments than the rest of the country
combined which presumes essentially that
a hundred percent of the elderly
population in miami-dade are HIV
positive versus knocking true right yeah
we have one the highest rates of STDs us
particularly in our elderly population
but like it's not possible they got
penis pumps for female patients that
they're billing for it's Medicare fraud
as a whole industry by the way Florida
you have always been weird feeling when
you're there like I whenever I'm in
Florida I feel like I've walked onto the
set of a movie and they're all making a
movie about me meaning that I don't know
what all of them like there's something
like the reveal is gonna be they're all
in on it
it's like Long Island in that what's
funny you should say that my producing
partner Alfred Spellman he describes it
as you remember the movie breakdown with
Kurt Russell yeah yeah so it's like it
never saw that your sister in New York
he's got the conversation scars back in
your shot I can't believe it he get
burned I get it
there's firefighters are heroes yeah
call dehorn
Russell and his wife are like driving
across the country to a new job or
something and they stopped in this like
truck stop kind of town with likes with
the sheriff and with the the gas station
and a bunch of shady like deliverance
type dudes and the wife disappears while
they're at the gas station and she's
been kidnapped and they want a ransom
and what slowly turns out CB radio where
all the clues were coming for a front
and spoiler alert but the movies like 25
years old so if you haven't seen it yet
it turns out that like everybody in this
town is in on it this is their hustle
that when that when like what they
perceive is like rich people come
driving through town they kidnap someone
that's Florida so hustles yes we don't
have a real industry and Carl hyacinth
says all we produce in Florida's oranges
and machine guns like we don't there's
no real industry there where there's no
state income tax so we subsist from
hustle to hustle which means that when
new people come in it's a transient
population tourism economy you come into
town we all we're all in on it we don't
grab you by the ankles turn you upside
down and shake all the money out of your
pockets and send you on your way no
brain break forever no good grifters
just a bunch right [ __ ] no good how
do you do they like trees [ __ ] do
they like you in Florida do they are you
are you because I'm on Angie oh you
could be a Florida legend in the sense
that you tell all these great Florida
stories but on the other end if you just
watched the Billy Corbin collection
Florida looks I mean as horrible as any
place you never look what is that what
is the flavor Floridians have for you
great you ask such rich question extra
sour key lime pie slightly sour on the
sour side there's the balance between
sweet and sour and a key lime pie is
fine strained no listen I'm a Florida
native and a lifelong Florida oh my was
Bobby always born in Fort Myers
lies that came true with swamp that
turned into Western floor that's right
old by the Gulf
yeah de tocar the way we do have
industry there though we make meth in
Walmart bathrooms that's in that on the
west coast well I hate to break it to
you meth is out and opiates are in Thank
You Ohio Pennsylvania Massachusetts in
origin yeah it's is it has anyone from
Florida approach to you like hey can you
do a [ __ ] cool like I can make it
look good yeah quarter could you do [ __ ]
it I don't know we have defense decent
state schools I would argue that I would
argue that all of our movies are twisted
love letters to our hometown you know
because I don't I I think that cooking
Cowboys did more for tourism than almost
anything over the last ten or fifteen
years people people see that movie for
whatever reason and say I gotta go they
they want to go in the cocaine to her
yeah they so so people do come in all
the time and say like I'm here because
people come to the University of Miami
they say because they they saw the you
documentary so I'm like what a response
our way dr. Tony listen not because they
saw screwball that's what happened with
Manny Ramirez I mean he gets busted yeah
and that publicity that word-of-mouth
attracted business to to Tony so and
I'll tell you when he was in prison this
is a an epilogue scene we ran out of
time and money to produce but when he
was in prison he was in a
minimum-security in camp in Alabama and
he was teaching his fellow prisoners
nutrition and he was inside with Jeff
Skilling of Enron who was teaching a
course on business yes and then they
were their fellow inmate was Jesse
Jackson Jr who was teaching a civics and
political science tan doctor a guy that
knew how to break the system coming from
Enron how long ago is that this was just
a few years ago he was just released I
think how much time did he recently not
enough it seems like Enron was a long
time ago 10 years yeah he did a while
sometimes they have like they'll have
dudes visit the set of billions they're
like in that world or whatever I was
like shaking everyone's hand and I was
like I met him and he's just so old rich
white dude to me and I was like hey nice
to meet you man and he walked away it
someone goes that's the guy that shorted
and wrong is that Ivan Boesky so that
guy me
a lot of money yeah like yeah yeah no he
made like yeah was he a criminal or no
no oh I'm shorted Enron when Enron was
[ __ ] juicing that he saw all the
[ __ ] and was smart enough to [ __ ]
short him but the guy didn't bail in the
big short yeah but he's just like he had
that I have so much energy I have so
much money I don't have to talk to
anyone energy like he was like yeah who
are you get the [ __ ] out of my way
pleasant no you didn't have to me guys
like a [ __ ] billionaire but he was
like yeah I don't know and someone told
me that I just I'm such an idiot that
I'm like hello sir like that guy shorted
around my and I wouldn't know what that
meant but it just sounds cool to know
that somebody shorted Enron show that's
impressive
I don't even know what that means you're
now saying it on a radio show there's
someone repeated to me in like a [ __ ]
parrot I'm just squatting in here like
you [ __ ] just stepped off a Wall
Street shirt and run this the Dow you
should do a documentary about me when
you live in Miami and you do something
like cocaine Cowboys you got Brewer like
bro I love that movie bro but like you
gotta interview my cousin bro cause he
knew all that [ __ ] bro you gotta talk to
Mike like bro he's done let's do some
walk up to a comic be like my buddy so
funny yeah so funny get the [ __ ] off
force one more gemandsam catch up with
full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM app